i got a haircut you know
uh adam got a haircut right yeah well i
paid some different prices from what i
understand
here we go all right there we go i need
it i go to get a haircut from this guy i
love this guy
great guy make i had rapper tony make a
video to send to him for me to go to get
a
haircut
and then time comes to pay 72 dollars
and 10 cents i'm like 72 bucks for a
haircut not tip
what was it 72 it's 70 bucks plus three
dollars for their fee
so three times seventy is two dollars
and ten cents so seventy dollars
i carry the two and then i'm not cooking
a fine i can respect the two seventy two
dollars for a hurricane
ten cents for the haircut all right by
the way here's here's the first thing i
thought about when i left
and we talked about it after it says why
do you have that reaction to it i said
look i've never paid 72
and 10 cents for a haircut and i've had
a lot of great haircuts tell me how you
determine your pricing he says well you
had an appointment with me and by the
way this guy's a die hard valuetainer
great guy
sweetheart of a guy you know we had the
other day we went and met him nice guy
and he did a great job
michael sent me a video i sent it to him
i said 7210
not including tippy says yes because
it's appointment only i said so how so
let me look at the haircut everybody
else was thirty dollars thirty five
dollars kids twenty oh so there's
pricing on the wall
pricing's on the wall but not the 72 and
10 cent pricing that's here so i go all
the way down and on the bottom it says
if you have an appointment it's five
dollars on top of whatever it is
35 bucks appointments no problem he said
celebrity hair
hairstylist nowadays is 72 dollars and
10 cents by the way you know what is
crazy
he is a celebrity in the barber
community no joke he's got massive
followers
when he says celebrity haircuts that
means because you're a celebrity no no
for him
the the the hairstylist and barbers
nowadays who have a following
they get these thousand dollar scissors
they get this equipment you know what's
the first thing i thought about
here's the first thing i thought about
every time i go to get a haircut i
always ask myself
why do barbers do it because think about
the math
35 bucks let's just say you work at a
place 35 bucks the owner takes what part
of the 30
35 50 percent knows you've got to pay a
fee for a chair of course that's the
part see the owner takes the
uh 20 bucks okay say you take 15 bucks
you keep 15 bucks of it because you got
to pay the rent
so you get another 10 tip that's 25 an
hour 25 bucks it takes an hour to give a
haircut
assuming you give eight in a day that's
how much money in the day 200
200 20 days in a month is what four
grand a month four grand times uh
12 is what 40 grand a year so the fact
that he got
60 no 48 thousand dollars a year a good
barber
makes barber makes right it's not a big
month it's not big money
i would think it's more than that to do
the math for me i don't know i just
you just did the math i don't need to
duplicate it so i thought it'd be more
so that's the point
yeah barbara at 35 bucks is only making
50 grand a year so when he charged me 72
10
i went in the car and the first thing i
said is i'm actually happy prices are
going up for barbers
no hell no let me tell you why let me
tell you why the fact that there is
tears
that people are willing to pay this kind
of money for somebody that does high
quality hair
you do the matter on the math on the
7210 how much does he keep on 7210
take the tip 15 additional bucks because
you do 2 uh 20 so it's thank you
whoa so it's 86 bucks well shout out to
caroline
shout out to gold what is going on so
say it's 86 bucks out of the 86 he keeps
60.
so he does eight haircuts in a day
that's what 480
times 20 in a month is what 10 grand a
month now the hair stylist is making
what six figures
good for him so but even at 72
haircut a great barber only makes
six figures per year okay think about
that they work when they want to work
they're not doing i don't know hard
labor here's what i want to find out
yeah i don't know about there's a lot of
jobs in america
how much do you pay for a haircut i pay
about 35 bucks 35 bucks now you're in
texas not complicated i go i go uh
the most i've ever paid 33 bucks yeah
okay most ever well you're in texas
yeah in la i assume when you were living
you know living your life in l.a same
girl cut my hair for 10 hours
i would love to hear from our audience
ladies and gentlemen how much
for the guys obviously because women i
actually want to know what is the most
you've ever paid for a haircut
and give us the city and the state but i
want to know just on average what they
pay
what do you pay adam what do you do who
do you got well it cuts themselves yeah
save that money it's usually it's just i
cut my
mario mario do this year watch this
how-to video on youtube and then every
time i see them in the kitchen together
yeah me and mario well they
usually it's about 35 bucks for a
haircut it's about 70 for celebrities
d-list celebrities are about 25 bucks so
i pay about 25 bucks
you're not a d-list celebrity yeah is
this the person you're going back to
like you've got a regular
you're in a i swear to god folks if you
were here on a daily basis adam's
probably the biggest celebrity in our
office
yes or no is he not the biggest
celebrity in the office employees are
taking pictures with just like a regular
now you have a regulator let's see
here's the thing that's a big deal
let's see here have you heard i've
noticed over time they're slowly getting
better i don't know if you've heard but
i'm kind of a big deal
you know okay armando lapeda says 40
bucks including beard can you tell us
where
where what city what city and state
wilberto rodriguez said 60 bucks i want
to know where did you say including beer
beard beard oh 72 is too much that's 40
dollars for a haircut
30 including tip honcho cheese got 45
bucks
la uh 50 bucks brian solaris is the
highest one so far
this one guy says 15 dogecoin
[Laughter]
15 dogecoin that's what that's uh last
week 750.
mobile okay here we go adrian brent
branigan
hundred dollar mobile barber in dc
that's that's good to know the market
price for mobile because you're driving
say you're taking out time
so it's an armored car if it's miami
adrian said 100 bucks 70 bucks oakland
75 in nashville 47. 85 bucks in
connecticut that makes it great what
about my boy roland i like his wife he
goes my mom gives me wait
wait a minute 85 encounters cortez 85 in
connecticut we have a friend in
greenwich that we need to give his name
to
50 miami and it's mobile he'll come to
you
greg i'm begging you go to this guy
that's a hundred bucks 85 bucks in
connecticut adrian bennegan 100 bucks so
you know what listen there's some people
that are
50 95 bucks in melbourne australia
and if you want him to fly out to use
three thousand dollars for that haircut
from australia
what else we got so listen qantas has
got summer deals
yeah 25 bucks 35 bucks you know
50 at home appointment in santa barbara
daniel castillo family cuts it so
you're looking at 50 bucks 60 bucks you
know you don't see a lot of 70.
but i did the math yesterday and here's
what happened when we left he says pat
yeah i'm sitting there he says pat give
us give us some ideas here give us some
wisdom we got a big vision here's what i
told them while we're with them
yesterday okay
and by the way today we're going to
finish the podcast at 10 30. so if
you're with us
hit the thumbs up button so we're going
to go going to subscribe we got to get
uh time on a flight and we'll be out
here we got appointments to run as well
here's what he asked me at the end this
is bad give me some feedback what do you
think i should do
i said okay i said do you want to be
known
as a great barber or do you want to be a
no known as a great businessman
what do you want to be known as that's a
great question yeah he says skill at
your profession or run a business yeah
because he says i want to i want to be
known as a great businessman i said then
you got to change your lens he says what
do you mean i said so let me do
something for you
so i step out i said i want you to think
i'm a celebrity barber
okay and i'm in boca i'm a celebrity
barber in miami
i'm a high premium like you i'm in boca
i'm checking out my competition i decide
to come and get a haircut from you
i walk into your barbershop everybody
knows so they're sitting there they're
listening i said yes
so i open the door i walk in i said if
i'm a celebrity barber and i sit here at
from which lens am i looking the entire
store here
he says what do you mean i said if i'm a
celebrity barber i'm probably checking
out your scissors
i said i'm probably looking at your 250
scissors says pat that's a thousand
dollars
that's great i said if i'm a celebrity
barber i'm watching how you do the fade
i'm watching how you talk to your client
i'm watching your style i'm watching
what products use i'm watching the kind
of stuff that you have there
do you do massage at the end do you have
a washing at the end you have beers
what i'm but i'm watching the way you
cut your hair from a celebrity barber
because i'm watching your abilities
right he says yes
i said let me go outside and come back
in so i go outside i come back in i said
i want you to know the next person
that's walking in
is a businessman okay that everything he
looks as through the lens of a
businessman fairy says fair so i walk
out
i come back and i sit he says while i'm
sitting here here's all i'm thinking
about
why are those three chairs open he's
losing money right there that guy just
did a haircut i've been waiting here for
30 minutes took him to get a haircut
what's the price 30 dollars
he gives him 20 bucks he keeps sending
15 bucks here
it took him this long to do a haircut
math i'm doing how many haircuts in an
hour
traffic cost electricity how much money
did he spend how much do those shares
cost
each chair how much is he spending how
much does he make i'm doing the math
right he said yes
i said you don't have the lens of a
business man your lens right now is a
lens of a barber
if you want to scale your business you
got to change the lens and start looking
at your business to scale
not looking at your business as i'm
selling 72 dollar haircuts because a 72
haircut you're making 100 grand a year
so if you got three four other barbers
you're making two you know a grand a
month off of these guys
you're really making what 161 seven
years that's not a million dollar
business that's a 116 that business so
the biggest challenge for some folks out
there who are either
the celebrity professional realtor or
the celebrity professional loan officer
the celebrity professional
whatever in any community chiropractor
do you want to be that
or do you want to be the one that has 40
chiropractor offices
20 real estate offices 30 mortgage
office it's a
in order to do the other part you got to
change your lens
simple as that great guy i gave him a
book he says
what do i need to do to get you back
here said i need you to read this book
you read it the moment you finish it
tell me you finish the book write a
paper on it i'll come back to get a
second haircut he boarded a book last
night so i got to go back and get a
haircut i think it's amazing
that number one you walk into the you're
just there to get a haircut
so what i'm seeing here is you're
identifying all the leaks and missed
opportunities in his business
so we we saw you just do this for those
of 100 lucky few
that were there at the sls meeting and
now we just launched
the fact that we're doing the the vault
uh that's gonna be what september first
yep
um these are the types of situations
where you go into a
barber shop and rather than oh i'm gonna
get my hair cut boom now you're
identifying leaks boom here you go you
got chairs open
here's a book i need you to read you
just totally changed this guy's life but
you know what's crazy here's what's
crazy here's what's crazy
if you look at tom okay if you look at
uh greg
if you look at you if you look at me sam
everybody in this room here right
the 21 year old pat when he walked into
the mall what lens did he have on what
do you think he was looking for just
looking to buy something i want to look
cool i'm just hanging out the 21 year
old pendant when you walked into the
mall
you're what if you weren't buying
anything the 21 year old pad walking
into the mall is only looking for
tight jeans nice legs nice you're
looking for chicks
that's my only lens was that so it was
the lens right see i gave you a little
more credit than that but
you think too highly of me at the 21
year old the twenty-one i didn't have a
lot of priorities so
yeah so then you look at another person
that goes in so everything about
everything we do
okay a mother walks in to a place
okay and they look at the living room a
father walks into the living room and
says oh my god look at the view look how
sick this is
look at the hotel look how sick the
windows a mother walks in and says oh
look at the edges of that table if the
kid hits his hair
we gotta that's the part if we can
change the lens
and the lens changes by the way half the
battle with what we got in america today
is we got some screwed up people with
lenses because we changed the lens we'd
actually get along and have
good discourse and good discussions and
debates together we have the wrong
lenses on tom
you know what's really interesting about
this and yeah pat you and i were in la
and there was a really amazing
haircutter he was a celebrity guy i
think his name was jose a bear
you may want someone to be able to look
look it up no nothing i'm just waiting
on my tea over here oh okay go ahead
on your teeth i thought he's a celebrity
i don't know he doesn't get what he
wants i don't get my tea i don't know
we're going to cancel the whole show
we just we just had the secret jose
about jose iberi bear i think it was his
name
yeah but he was uh he used to wear like
a white cowboy hat and he had this huge
brand and what he did was he realized
that
having all these celebrity clients
wasn't the path to making money
and my understanding was he used himself
as the branded magnet
and he hired really good stylist and so
he turned it into a business where he
always had his chairs full
and he brought great people in that want
to be associated with him and he was
doing
high-end celebrity and then a lot of
wealthy people
and beverly hills i always had a lot of
respect for that i said wow he's kind of
figured this out
that he can only do so many haircuts but
he's the magnet
you know what i'm saying he's the magnet
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]